[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJA HAMMERLY: So welcome to
a session on Stackdriver.
I'm Aja Hammerly, and
I like it when people
tweet at me during my talks.
My Twitter is @the_thagomizer,
which is spelled exactly
as you think it is.
And if you come up
afterward, I can tell you
the story behind that.
Today, we're going to
talk about Stackdriver,
so let's get a little
bit of show of hands
first-- figure out who all
is in the audience today.
So who's used
Stackdriver before?
OK, awesome.
Who's using it in
production right now?
Smaller set, not surprising.
And who in the audience has a
DevOps, sysadmin, ITOps type
of title?
OK, smaller group
than I was expecting.
How many people who just think
of themselves as developers
here?
Awesome, OK.
So I work at Google as
a developer advocate,
but before I worked at Google,
I worked in ITOps, DevOps--
whatever you want to call it.
The title seems to
change every week.
And one of my jobs
was racking servers.
This is not actually a
picture of one of the servers
I racked, but many of
mine looked like this.
I also carried a pager
for about three years.
I was half of our on-call team.
Who here has done
the pager thing?
Yeah.
Not necessarily
everyone's favorite task.
And I did a lot of
production issue debugging,
including connecting my trusty
dev laptop to production.
And I know I'm not the
only one who's done that,
even though it's a bad idea.
So why am I talking
about Stackdriver?
One of the things I really
like about Stackdriver
is that all the
tools come together.
Everything is there,
everything is integrated.
When I was doing this
work, before Google,
I was using one tool
for log aggregation,
another tool for
crash reporting,
another tool for application
performance monitoring,
and then a pile of
tools for monitoring--
Pingdom, Monnit, all
of the above, Nagios.
And whenever something
went really wrong,
everything would turn red.
And it was really
hard to figure out
what was actually going
on because everything
was alerting simultaneously.
It was also annoying when
someone would join or leave
the team because I
had to grant them
accounts on all
of those systems,
or take their accounts
away when they left.
And Stackdriver does
all of those things.
It has a lot of that
functionality already built-in,
and it's all integrated.
So that's one of the
reasons that I'm super
excited about Stackdriver.
But I could get up
here and give you
the marketing pitch for an hour,
and we would all get bored,
including me, so
instead, we're going
to live debug a website using
the Stackdriver toolchain
while I'm standing here.
So I made a simple
Rails website,
running on App Engine
Flex, which we announced
is now GA as of this morning.
Yes, it supports Ruby.
This is my website, Cat or
Not, also known as Tindpurr.
And you can upload your cat,
you can vote on the cats,
and you can see all the cats.
And I'll give you a
quick demo of this.
So here's all of
the cats that people
have uploaded to Tindpurr.
As you can see, I have
some performance issues
I baked into this so we
have stuff to look at later.
But this is what
happens when you
send an email to the entire
team saying, show me your cats.
There's some pretty cute
ones you can look at.
And if you wanted to upload
a cat, you could do that.
Standard basic upload form.
And for voting on cats, using
the material design UI--
oh, Chuck Norris and Rambo.
The picture didn't load.
Let's try a different one.
So I could vote.
There they are.
So that's all there
is to this website.
So here's the
basic architecture.
Running it on App
Engine, as I said,
which means I don't care how
many servers I have running,
App Engine takes care of it.
I wanted some sort of
back end processing
because I don't know
any real websites that
don't have some sort
of back end processing,
so there's a Pub/Sub
queue set up behind this,
and when someone
uploads a cat, it
calculates which cats
still need more votes
and populates the queue.
And then when you go to vote for
cats, it pulls from that queue.
A little contrived, but,
you know, demo apps.
And then I'm using Cloud SQL
running MySQL as my back end.
So also interesting,
I'm doing a talk
to a bunch of DevOps/sysadmin
people or people
who like to break
things, I hope.
And if I'm doing that
talk, it's really boring
if there's no load
on my website.
So I spun up Apache
Bench, and is currently
hitting a bunch of
URLs from my website,
just doing get requests--
relatively simple,
but it's better than no load.
And that's running
in the background.
I'm running it on a
Compute Engine instance.
So let's say I'm taking
Tindpurr to production.
I need some monitoring.
And the first thing I
need is uptime monitoring.
One of my general rules
of thumb with monitoring
is I don't want to monitor
anything that if it goes wrong,
I can't fix it.
So sometimes it's
nice to know things,
but if there's no direct
action you can take,
why do you want to be broken up?
So let's set up an uptime check.
Actually, I've gotten
an uptime check set up.
This is going to be a
very demo-heavy talk.
So I'm just using the
standard uptime check
in Stackdriver for App Engine.
We're going to look at it.
And earlier today, the Virginia
site was failing, but now
it's back up.
I can see exactly where
things are going on.
I can also see a track
of my response codes.
This may correlate to when
I started up Apache Bench.
And you can also see my response
latency, and what's going on.
And this all comes for free.
I just logged into Stackdriver
for the first time.
They're like, you have
an App Engine app.
I'm like, yes.
Yes, I do.
And this is the
standard uptime check
that comes with App Engine.
So that's the basic
stuff done, but I also
want to check my
database and make sure
that that's being
monitored, so let's set up
some monitors on that.
Cloud SQL.
So I can see I had a
spike of queries here
and I haven't had
any queries recently.
That's a little suspect,
so I'm going to set up
a new policy for that.
Select Metric rate of
change on Cloud SQL.
Applies to all of them.
And if my read ops decreases
by 15% over 15 minutes,
that seems like something's
probably not right.
I can only go up to eight.
And I'm going to be notified.
And I'll be notified as
thagomizer@google.com.
So now I've set up a basic
policy on my database.
If I'm not getting
enough read ops,
I'm assuming that load has
gone down for some reason.
Likely, something's wrong.
The other kind of
thing I like to check
when I'm doing App Engine
is I like to set up
a policy on the response codes.
I showed the graph
earlier where a show I
have a lot of 500
response codes there.
That's a little suspect.
I probably should have
gotten alerted to that.
So I'll make a new
policy for that, as well.
And it's applying
to my Cat or Not,
which was the other
name for my app.
The 500 responses are above.
We'll go with 30 for a minute.
30.
I want to be notified.
And you saw the
blue line show up
that shows where
that is, so I would
have been notified earlier
today if that had happened.
And this time, I'll have it
notify me with the Console app.
Name it.
And now I've got two
basic alerts set up.
But that's not all
Stackdriver can do.
One of the many things it can
also do is error reporting.
And this is one of the
things I really like,
because if you've set
up Stackdriver logging,
it pulls in your logs and
it analyzes them, and finds
clusters of errors,
and lets you know
when things have errored out.
And it doesn't show you the
same error of 10,000 times,
it groups them.
You dive in, you can see
a simple trace of that.
And it happens to be
that my phone just
alerted, so let's dig into it.
That may have been planned.
So if I go to Error
Reporting, let's
see if the latest error is here.
This is the one
I was looking at.
I have the Google Cloud
Console app on my phone.
And so I'm getting an undefined
method pick for fixnum 32,
and that seems ungood.
And I got the whole
stack trace here,
a bunch of stuff in Rails.
How many Rubyists/Rails
developers
do I have in the audience?
I assume relatively few.
More than I expected.
Yay, Ruby.
And so some things I
can do when I get here.
I can link to the issue
if I had a bug tracker.
I can just put URL in here.
I can look at the raw
stack trace, which may be
more useful in some languages.
I can see that it
yielded a 500 message,
and that the first one
was seen 56 minutes ago,
and it was seen in this
particular App Engine version.
And I can actually
make it happen
because I know how it happens.
Oh, it didn't happen that time.
But we'll dig into it.
So now I know that
I have this error,
and I want to actually
look at it in the logs
and in my source.
I'll switch over to the logs.
So I'm just looking at
Stackdriver logging for my Ruby
app.
If you're using any of our App
Engine or client libraries,
it will automatically show up.
To get all the stuff
working with Ruby,
I just installed
the Stackdriver gem.
I didn't have to actually
do any configuration at all.
It's just straight
drop-in, and a lot
of the libraries for web
frameworks work that way.
Look at this, and I can
also filter by log level.
That was the Cloud SQL
database, App Engine.
I want error or above.
And I want my Ruby app log.
Here's all my errors, and I
can see them here, as well.
This links to Error Reporting.
There's the error again.
I can mute an error.
And so at this point, I
have a pretty good idea
of where this piece of
code that's failing is.
So this is the point where I
would normally jump into debug.
Stackdriver has a
built-in debugger,
but it is currently
pre-alpha for Rails,
and I went to try
it out this morning
and it's not quite
working, so we're
going to actually drive
straight into my editor instead.
So welcome to Emacs.
So I happened to write this.
This to do-- this is broken.
And the issue I have here is
that I'm pulling all the votes
from a Pub/Sub queue,
and I'm not actually
refreshing that Pub/Sub
queue except when
people upload new cats.
So if the queue empties,
I end up pulling null.
And then I try to do a
bunch of stuff with null,
and that doesn't work so well.
So what I need to do is
if there is no next cat,
next cat equals
cats cat.all.sample,
which, in Ruby, just pulls
me a single random one
from the whole
entire list of cats.
So now I've done that.
I'm going to deploy
to App Engine
live because live
demos are awesome.
And that's going to
take a little bit,
but I need to hit
Yes first, so we're
going to go back to the slides.
So I've talked about some
parts of the Stackdriver suite.
I've talked a little
bit about monitoring.
I showed you a
little about logging.
Logging can also
export to BigQuery.
I really like BigQuery.
I frequently give
talks on BigQuery
because it's amazingly
powerful, and I
don't have to learn a special
query language to use it.
So if you have a lot of logs
and you're, like, you know,
this interface isn't
working for me to, like,
dig in in the regular
Stackdriver logging interface,
you can just export to BigQuery
and use SQL or JavaScript
to search your logs.
Talked a little
bit about debugger.
One of the awesome
things about debugger
is that you can debug
live on production.
And it isn't like your
normal stepping debugger,
but it still allows you to
debug live on production
without connecting your
dev box to production,
which is good in my world.
But the big thing I haven't
mentioned about Stackdriver
is that it's cross-cloud.
Most of the features
I've showed you
work just as well on
AWS as they do on GCP.
I've shown them on GCP--
it's GCP Next-- but you can
also do all the monitoring,
all the logging, all the error
reporting, on AWS, as well.
Or if you're one of
those people who's
working in a cross-cloud
environment, which
lots and lots of
people are now, you
can have all of your information
from both places in one place.
You can set up the exact
same alerts for AWS and GCP.
At Google I/O last
year, I had a database
where my master
was running in GCP,
and I had the replica
running in AWS,
and I had all the same
alerts on both of them.
And the idea was that it
was a hot swappable setup,
so if one of my two
providers went down,
I could switch and not
have as much downtime.
So other nice thing
about monitoring
is we have monitoring
that's set up
for a lot of the common
open source tools.
This list is not exhaustive,
but I've used it was Mongo,
I've used it with
Memcached, I've
used it with MySQL,
Nginx, Redis, RabbitMQ.
And often, if you have these
and you have the agent running,
it will look at the
name of the instance
and the ports that are open,
and will make available to you
in the UI the metrics that
you are most likely to want,
because it has a pretty good
idea what you're running.
If you're running MySQL you have
port 3306, I believe, running
and it's named my
MySQL instance.
It's pretty sure that
you're running MySQL.
And if it's wrong, you
can tell it it's wrong,
but that's really
handy and it saves time
when you're setting stuff up.
Also, we have metrics for
a lot of our tool set,
not surprisingly.
I showed you some of the
stuff for App Engine.
You can look at reserved
cores, CPU usage--
that kind of thing.
We have our DOS protection.
You can see if that's
been triggered.
For compute, CPU utilization,
uptime, read and write.
BigQuery-- who here
has a really good idea
how to monitor a
giant data warehouse?
I didn't.
And there's stuff we've built
for BigQuery with the BigQuery
team that makes sense.
So uploaded bytes,
scanned bytes, how many
queries you have going on.
I did a blog post two weeks
ago about different ways
that you can monitor
BigQuery using Stackdriver.
Firebase-- super popular,
awesome set of tools.
You can monitor that, as well.
And the Stackdriver team and the
Kubernetes and Container Engine
team were working together
to build monitoring
for container-based
systems, which is something
that a lot, a lot of folks
have figured out exactly
how to do yet.
If you want to know more
about all the metrics we
have available, the URL's here.
This talk will be
recorded and online.
Yesterday's talks showed up
before midnight last night,
so 48 hours or less, hopefully.
And alerting.
So you saw me choose
that I could get email.
I got alerted by
the app on my phone.
I could also get
an SMS to my phone.
I've worked at places
that use PagerDuty.
We connect with PagerDuty.
You can use Slack, you can use
HipChat, you can use Campfire.
That covers a lot of
the stuff that people
use for managing their
teams and figuring out
what's going on in places
that they're looking
for their notifications.
So we talked about
error reporting.
There's lots of
great features here,
and one of the
other things I like
is that you can
configure alerts,
and the alerts
automatically know
when to stop telling you
about the same thing happening
over and over again.
Not only does it
group it, if you
get over a certain number
of alerts in an hour,
it shuts up, because it
figures you know at that point
and you're dealing
with it-- you just
haven't been able to make
everything go quiet yet.
Debugger.
I have played with debugger.
It's currently
available for Java, Go,
Node is beta, and Python.
And it's not your normal
stepping debugger.
You upload your code or
you point the debugger
at a Cloud repo
or a GitHub repo,
you figure out the line of
code you want it to look at,
you set a watch
point, and it will
catch an in-flight request,
snapshot at that point,
give you all the
variable values,
give you the stack
trace, and then
it'll let the request finish.
So then you have all the
details about what was going on.
So if you have that
situation where you're like,
OK, the stack trace
says it's on that line.
How the heck is it
getting to that line?
Why does it have a null
value at that line?
I don't understand.
You can set that watch point.
You don't have to push
an instrumented version
of the code.
You can just do it live.
And depending on exactly the
runtime you're running in,
it adds some latency
but not a heck of a lot.
Some of the languages are better
at handling that than others.
Language runtimes--
they're all different.
So I was going to demo debugger.
I'll show you what it
looks like, at least,
so you can see approximately
what it would look like.
So I'm going to--
oh, you're doing things.
Wouldn't be a live demo
if everything didn't
go exactly the way I wanted.
So I have my Cat or Not
folder, and here's all my code.
And the controllers.
Here's the votes controller
I was looking at earlier.
There's the code that
I've changed already.
And you can see that
it does not currently
support the Ruby runtime.
I actually have the debugger
library, the gem, installed,
but I'm not hitting a
staging version of our app
because they won't let
me at this conference,
so I can't actually
show you live.
But it's coming.
It's pre-alpha.
It should be alpha soon.
But you can see how you can just
set a breakpoint in the side
here, and get all
the data of the app
while it's running live.
And you can see your
snapshot history.
You can also look at your logs.
So the only thing I haven't
showed you yet is trace.
And I've done a lot of work
with a lot of different tools
that are trying to keep
track of my performance
of my application while
I'm working on it.
And this one's pretty awesome.
So I can look at a specific
trace for a specific request
that was slow.
Came back.
There we go.
And you can see that it took 312
milliseconds-- not particularly
long, but longer than I'd like.
Most of that was done
in this new method,
which is what I'd expect.
Here was the SQL portion where
it was reading active record,
doing the query.
Here's the stuff where it
was doing the rendering.
And you can also
look at the details--
the time stamp, the trace time,
the untrace time, what status
code it returned,
and a whole bunch
of other interesting things
and size of the response that
had happened.
I can also look at
analysis reports.
So here's the auto
analysis for my root.
And this is a
latency over time--
25%.
So you can see the
different graphs,
and see the latency
in milliseconds
for the root of the application
at various times, the 95% case,
and how it was doing
week over week,
I believe this is what this is.
Cumulative distribution,
seeing different ways
of visualizing the same data.
So one of the things
you may have noticed
is that my Show
All the Cats page
does not have any sort
of pagination at all,
and it is doing a pretty
intensive query because it
is actually showing you the cats
in order by most popular cat,
and it's doing the
averaging of all their votes
in the database.
And so here is all of the
requests in the analysis
for all of my requests to /cats.
You can see that this one
was particularly long.
I can click on it.
I can get the
information about that.
Most of the time was
spent not in SQL.
It actually looks like it
was waiting on the server.
But I can also look at other
requests that took a long time.
Showing render time
versus waiting time.
That was likely one of the
ones that was caught up
while Apache Bench was running.
And I get all this
summary information.
I can also limit that
URL by HTTP method,
by the status code
if we had any 500s.
No 500s today.
And also which parts
of the service--
I've only got one
App Engine service--
and which versions
of App Engine I'm
using if I have
multiple versions.
So let's see if my
deployment has completed.
It has.
Let's actually do it this
way It's now spinning up.
You can see the load on my
App Engine as it comes up.
Come on, you can do it.
Wouldn't be a live demo
if it didn't go sideways.
So you've seen how all
the pieces fit together
while this is loading.
I'll demo in just a
second when it loads
that the voting works again.
You maybe didn't
see, but I told you,
and it really is
true, that all I
did to get all this
instrumentation was quite
literally include
gem Stackdriver
in my manifest, my gemfile.
Same thing works with Node.
And if the tools
aren't available yet
for any of the other seven
languages that we support,
they're on their way.
We're working on them right now.
And I love that I don't
have to configure anything.
I don't have to
install an agent.
I don't have to, like, get a
set of keys for some third party
service and make sure
that the right keys are
on the production server and
that the devs don't have them
so that the dev data isn't
polluting my production data.
Everyone's accounts,
everyone's access
is controlled in one
central place with IIM,
and it's all there.
All the basic tool sets
that I need are there.
And as someone who's had
to debug stuff for ages
upon ages upon ages before--
yay, my cats came up.
Oh, and the current winning
cat is the animated GIF cat.
So everything's there.
Everything's there,
and I don't have
to do a bunch of
extra work for it.
So let's see if we
can vote on cats now
that I've fixed my bug.
Oh, and it even
showed me my cat.
That's Emma.
[INAUDIBLE] 8.
We'll see if it crashes.
And the bug is fixed.
It didn't run out
of queue length.
It's randomized now.
So I want to thank the team
who helped me with this talk.
The app and stuff is
mine, but I got some help
from the Stackdriver team, and
specifically the Stackdriver
Ruby team, because I told
them a month ago, hey,
I'm going to demo all
your stuff on stage.
You should probably get it done.
And they had all the libraries
done for me this morning,
including the debug
library, and it was my fault
that it didn't get
fully included.
There's a bunch of
resources available
if you want to learn
how to use this stuff.
Here are a bunch of links--
cloud.google.com/productname--
stackdriver, monitoring,
logging, debugger,
error_reporting with
an underscore, trace.
[MUSIC PLAYING]